le procès que toute la belgique attend
il débutera lundi celui de marc dutroux
le pédophile belge est incarcéré depuis
août 96 la population veut maintenant
connaître la vérité sur les
circonstances de l'enlèvement de six
fillettes et la mort de quatre d'entre
elles chaque soir jusqu'à lundi nous y
reviendrons voici d'abord le rappel de
cette affaire qui avait provoqué une
vive douleur dans le pays et bien au
delà
pascal justice et marc felix en plein
mois d'août de l'année 96
les belges découvrent une bande de
malfaiteurs en quelques heures
marc dufour de serre ailleurs michelle
martin son épouse et michel lelièvre le
conflit ce toxicomane vous plonger le
pays dans l'effroyable univers d'un
kidnappeur d'enfants dans les sous sols
de ces deux missiles qui l'a lui même
aménagé marc dutroux a séquestré au
moins six fillettes
toutes ont été violées et pour quatre
d'entre elles la mort était au bout du
calvaire seul sabine et laetitia en sont
sorties vivantes
c'était le 15 août 96 le début de l'
affaire dutroux
quelques jours plus tard
en creusant les jardins des différents
domiciles de dutroux on découvre les
dépouilles de julie melissa anne et
essieux la belgique chancel de douleur
vient ensuite l'indignation
je suis plus révoltés contre la justice
du cot marc dutroux l'ajuster savent
bien que c'est un film le fait les comme
l'appelle le père de mélissa a déjà été
condamné pour séquestration et viol de
mineure suspect numéro 1 dès le
lendemain de la disparition de julie et
mélissa marc dutroux est surveillé par
la gendarmerie pendant cinq mois son
domicile et même perquisitionné en vain
alors que les fillettes sont enfermées
dans la cave
alors on s'interroge qui est responsable
d'un tel ratage du trou et est il
protégé travail est il pour un réseau
arrêté deux jours après marc dutroux
michel nihoul est soupçonné d'être le
commanditaire de l'enlèvement de
laetitia homme d'affaires condamné à
plusieurs reprises pour banqueroute
frauduleuse
michel nihoul se vante d'avoir organisé
des parties fines pour la haute société
belge mais nie toute implication dans un
réseau pédophile
en octobre 96 l'indignation des belges
tourne à la colère à cause cette fois
d'une décision de justice le juge
d'instruction jean marc conrad a
participé à un dîner de soutien aux
familles des victimes et la cour de
cassation y voit un signe de partialité
la population elle ne comprend pas qu'on
écarte de l'anc est celui qu'elle
considère comme un héros
depuis la libération de sabine et
laetitia pendant une semaine
la belgique connaît un climat pré
insurrectionnel de grève générale et de
manifestations axe symbolique les
pompiers arrosent le tribunal pour laver
la justice il faudra l'intervention des
familles de victimes pour que la marche
blanche déroule dans le calme marquant
le silence dans le temps et dans la
dignité parce que nous l'appelons 2100
trois cent cinquante mille personnes
dans la rue en mémoire des petites
victimes
jamais la belgique ne s'étaient
mobilisés de la sorte pour calmer les
esprits une commission parlementaire est
chargé de mettre au jour les
dysfonctionnements de l'enquète
incompétence mauvaise transmission des
informations guerre des polices
le rapport rendu six mois plus tard et
sans concession le constat est tragique
si les bonnes décisions avaient été
prises en 95
les enfants auraient sans doute été
retrouvé peut-être même vivante
la chronique du déroulement de cette
enquête est la chronique d'un échec à
nous pendant qu'on analyse les erreurs
du passé l'enquète continue sous la
direction d'un nouveau juge
d'instruction jacques langlois qui ne
cache pas son point de vue marc dutroux
est un pervers isolé et michel nihoul
n'a pas sa place au procès mais la
justice belge ne le suis pas michel
nihoul sera bien jugé arlon aux côtés de
michel lelièvre michelle martin et marc
dutroux
un procès sous haute surveillance pour
éviter que marc dutroux ne s'échappe
comme il le fit le 23 avril 98 pendant
quelques heures ce jour-là les belges
effaré
on saisit t entre le rire et les pleurs
à paris